foreign
you guys ready to go yeah let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
the robe just broke Luke Tom and Nate
here with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and today
we are going to be camping and exploring
this deserted island
welcome to another episode of the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel and today
we're doing another camping video but
this time we are going to be camping on
our very own deserted island
how about that and not only that we're
gonna try to catch ourselves some dinner
and cook it up and eat it as well and uh
and if we're lucky we might do a little
exploring here see what we can find on
this cool Island all right guys you
ready to set up camp
but it looks like he already found some
food
yeah look at that look at that oh what
is that that is yeah well that's a
muscle
that's a big one too yeah you can eat
these I know look oh there's one over
there in there oh yeah they're delicious
we're gonna we boil them up we steam
them up see this line of grass that's
where the the water came up to
so we have got to get above that
oh
foreign
got to be really careful with the tides
it's about an hour before high tide and
so the tide was coming with us so we
were helped by the tide and we burned up
about a quarter a tank of gas now going
back will take us more gas if we're
going against the tide so I got to be
careful with that also I've got to be
careful because I've beached my boat
right and the Tide's gonna go out and
leave it high and dry so I gotta watch
that as well I just want to set up the
camp real quick then we're gonna go out
and drop some crab pots and try to catch
some crabs for our food and I got some
fishing rods here we're going to try to
set that up as well we've got some deep
ish water over here there's a nice
little candle that goes right within
casting distance of the shore here so
this should be a good fishing spot as
well as a good camping spot let's see
what we can do your hand stuck yeah
foreign
well it's kind of windy and I really
need to stake this tent down but these
little metal stakes that come with it
are garbage so I'm gonna really quick go
make some steaks
well I got the 10 up and the boys are
taking a sand bath I think I need to go
catch some crabs so uh let's pull out
the pots
so these are my crab pots I'm allowed to
use two at a time and they've got this
little bait pouch here in the top
and I just put any sort of meat uh fish
in there I've got some dead shad
all right I got the pots baited up and
you go drop them out I'm gonna go out
about oh 100 200 yards out there with
the skiff and just Chuck the pots in
about four or five feet of water let it
soak until about dinner time and then
we'll uh we'll see what we got in our
pots
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I gotta tell you this boat handles so
much better without all that firewood
camping gear
all right Nate you want to throw one
okay throw it and make sure that this
side goes down that okay you don't want
it to flip upside down okay go for it
check it
all right there we go you ready to go
fast
not as fast as you can
all right I want to do a little bit of
fishing here I brought three surf rods
and a variety of rigs I'm not sure what
we'll catch it's still really early in
the air it's kind of cold frankly even
though it's really sunny out here it's
like 50 degrees in the daytime 40 30 in
the night we probably have skates out
here maybe blow toads or puffer fish
spot
um speckled trout maybe
uh you know things like that we just
really don't know it's early in the year
and it's still kind of cold frankly it's
not ideal but let's see if we can't
catch something
so I got a little high low rig with
these little foam beads and some long
shank J Hooks number four whale tongue
lead just kind of the basic setup you
get when you're chucking a rig out into
the bay and you don't quite know what
you're gonna get got some of these fish
bites here they work good as bait stops
it's keeping your your bait from flying
off the the hook that shrimp will want
to come off the hook when you cast and
that little bit of uh fish bite will
keep it from backing off the hook
Earth
[Music]
y
check it out I broke the tip off my rod
my very first cast the tip of my rod
broke off and I don't know why love this
rod
well it's about four o'clock it's high
tide and I'm gonna let those rods sit
out right there as the Tide's changing
maybe look at getting the boys a little
snack or something and uh just gonna
relax a little bit
that's it an X and there's an arrow
s the spot
Nathan have you gotten yourself wet yep
yep are you gonna go for a swim yep yep
all right Tom are you going for a swim
yeah all right well it's 55 degrees and
the boys say they want to go for a swim
so we'll see we'll see how they like
that run in there
are you gonna get in
you know if you put your life jacket on
it'll warm you up a little bit
you warming up Nathan yep
angel you're making a sand Angel oh
you're getting so gross Nathan told me
he needs to use the bathroom I just told
him to go behind those trees over there
the boys are having such a good time I
don't think there's anything I can see
or do to get them back into that boat
we're gonna take it nice and easy
tonight we're gonna cook up some food uh
try to catch some dinner and tomorrow
we're going to be doing some exploring
the very end of the island way over
there you can see a small Grove of trees
apparently there are the ruins of an old
building that's abandoned down there
this truly is a deserted island and
we're gonna go try to see if we can find
the ruins and explore them a little bit
tomorrow we'll see if we got enough gas
to make it down there and and whatnot
but uh I'm excited well we've been
fishing for about an hour not a bite and
I'm only in about four or five feet of
water I cast out as far as I could and I
didn't quite make it out into that
channel out there so I think I'm gonna
reel in my gear and use this skiff to
drop my bait out there in the channel
and see if that doesn't help
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I am almost completely out of line there
all right I got both those rods in the
deep water we'll let that sit and see if
we do any good
hey Nate you cold buddy yeah okay let's
get you dried off okay the sun's gonna
be setting soon it's going to get real
cold
warmer now
I think the Silver Rod just got a bite
it just went
yeah
oh we might catch something here all
right Tom you want to reel in the rods
oh I'll kill you
no problem buddy
oh look at this look at this we got a
shark what
what is I got a sork here here hold it I
caught a snake
look at that
our first fish
ing
my life yeah is that your first shark
yes I never
okay I
turn around
turn them around
okay
and just let him go and as soon as he's
ready to swim off
see oh he's swimming back he's gonna
come over and bite my foot
there he's going right under the boat
that he's not gone
hide out under the boat oh he's
following me
I was walking back and he was right
behind my foot
he's got a nibble
foreign
gets dark I'm going to set up our
sleeping bags here
I bought this tent two years ago in our
sturgeon fishing trip in British
Columbia and it's just been a great
little tent it was like 35 Canadian
dollars
these right here are negative 20 bags
from Bass Pro Shop and these right here
are the little kids size summer bags
these are like 20 degree 30 degree bags
and I've got one for Nate and one for
Tommy and I'm going to stuff those
inside the negative 20 bag
um Nathan probably doesn't need it that
kid can stay warm in the middle of a
snowstorm Tommy gets cold so easily and
he's a little hesitant about going
camping with me unless I can guarantee
his warmth and so we're bringing lots
lots of bags
check out my uh my camping duffel bag it
says clean on that side dirty on that
side take off your dirty clothes you
shove it in the dirty side and keeps all
your clothes organized well the sun's
gonna set in about an hour and a half so
let's reel in the rods and uh go check
the Crab Pot see what's going on there
okay can you reach over and get it
okay get it this is all you
you got it now pull it up
oh look at that pull it up Tom pull it
grab the net grab it
look at that we've got crabs
oh I'm wrapped up I'm wrapped up I'm
gonna throw that overboard
all right sit down Tom right there okay
oh
yep barely
let's see and this one's out the mail
okay let's go let's see
there we go that big boy he's the
biggest one all right three tiny Keepers
all right you wanna go get some more
yeah all right let's do it
for our look for our boy where is it
Nathan
well we pulled both pots and we got five
keeper crabs and we're gonna have crab
dinner you guys excited yeah yeah I know
how to pick them up all right see if you
can do it got him attention to the
bottom there you go buddy so you give
them something to hold on to and they
kind of calm down here why don't you go
ahead and put that in there
Nathan do you want to try picking one up
yeah got him yeah
good job that one's like
there we go
all right let's let's take it over let's
get a fire started shall we
all right we're gonna go ahead and build
a fire but we want to build it below the
high tide Mark so that the next high
tide will wash it all away and it won't
kill all this grass which is important
to maintaining the dunes
what are they definitely in the autobot
[Music]
got my blast match here
hey boys will you grab me some wood
[Music]
luckily I have a bunch of leftover
lumber from the fishing cabin project
and the hand cart project so uh we're
having a scrap wood fire today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Walmart
it's really for eating is what yours
here
all right
got Old Bay
levels
the old days clothes visit used to be a
fire they would make a fire and watch
television
sit on the cooler
that's it
boys
well the tide turned I was meaning to
take the boat out deeper but I got
distracted
better start pushing
there you go the Sun is setting the
crabs are steaming the boys are playing
this is good
hey you guys cold you want some hot
chocolate yeah okay well I'm gonna make
you some hot chocolate okay
I'm so cold
just before bedtime I like to put these
adhesive body warmers on the kids I
can't tell you enough how great these
are as a parrot they just throw them in
your bag your kids get cold slap a bunch
of these on them
I'll do it on the inside okay over here
I'm feeling much glad I thought I came
along
it's just like so adventurous
all right here
oh
my that is looking good right there
oh yeah that is all good okay guys why
don't you tell me what you want and I'll
load up your food okay
potato
shrimp what
crab you're gonna take that and start
eating on it you gotta eat that I'm
gonna eat
nummy that's that's the Poo you
a lot of poo
a poo free muscle you take that
oh there's a big piece of crab right
there
look at that
like that
delicious
Orange
expecting my dinner
it's really hot
oh guys look at those stars look at the
clear sky
you guys having fun yeah good I really
want the cats more more starts you ready
for bed
it's late it's past your bedtime
take your feet in the air like you just
don't care
naughty feet
okay no go inside feed
burn this all up
[Music]
all right
I wouldn't put away the mess kits and
everything and they are sound asleep
those boys just zonked out well it's
late and I gotta get to bed but it has
been years since I've seen so many stars
it's Crystal Clear there's no moon and
no man-made light it's just
amazing but it's late and I gotta get to
bed and I am anxious to see if we can
explore the rest of this island
including those ruins tomorrow so I'll
see you guys in the morning
good morning
oh it's pretty
what a beautiful sight and good the
boat's still here
[Music]
good morning guys
do you have a good sleep tone
I'll make you some hot chocolate and
bacon and oatmeal How about that
okay
the Blackbeard the pirate used to use
this island as a Heidi Place
you know that like that's true story
Island packing
I think the wind I think the wind picked
up a little bit
hot chocolate first
[Music]
all righty I am going to eat some lemon
cake lemon cake bacon sandwich people
[Music]
that's really good oh yeah that hot
chocolate good yep
well I really want to take the boys and
go explore the abandoned mansion at the
other part of the island
but a couple factors have popped up
first off I don't have as much gas in
the tank as I thought I did so I'm a
little worried about getting there and
back with the gas we have Additionally
the wind's kicking up the forecast has
changed a little bit we've got about six
to 11 mile per hour winds right now and
it's supposed to kick up to 20 in the
afternoon
I don't mind the win normally but with
this boat fully loaded down that makes
me a little concerned so what I'm
thinking we should do is hurry and pack
up the boat and take all the gear back
to the car get some more gas and then go
explore
what do you think was this a cool spot
yeah this is a pretty neat camping trip
well let's go get the Crab Pot shall we
yeah okay
okay
oh
take the fire you can't take the logs
and kick him into the water
flaming sucker
well we went to go get our pot and it's
gone I also noticed that some of the
other pots in the neighborhood are gone
too so I think somebody nabbed our pot
I could see the other boy over there so
we're gonna go get the other one
oh yeah it's got a few
look at that guy all right we'll let him
go
hey look at this got a big old Wilk
shell in here
you can eat them but they're not very
good
oh we've had to slow down the waves are
getting too big
[Music]
foreign
there we go
you know we've only got about six to 11
mile per hour winds right now and the
waves were a little bit sketchy right at
the end there it it really made me
nervous so I don't think we should be
going out when we're expecting to get up
to 20 mile per hour winds this afternoon
that just wouldn't be smart but I really
wish we got a chance to explore that
Mansion if you guys would like to see us
come back and explore that Mansion make
sure to click that like button and let
us know and then we'll come out here on
a calmer day and give it another try do
you guys want to go explore that Mansion
yeah
did you guys have fun on this camp out
yeah this was a pretty cool experience
if you guys like this sort of thing make
sure to check out our camping and
survival video playlist and we put out
new videos every Saturday morning so
don't forget to click
s if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]